- Let's see what I was reacting to.
(screaming)
How do I not lose my voice?
(upbeat music)
I'm deranged.
(laughing)
No no no no no no.
No no no no.
Oh, I remember this!
(screaming)
I'm loving
I'm doing it again.
I am a lot.
What's up y'all?
So no matter how many
cool things I get to do
on my show
I react
well, in a large way.
(laughing)
I have a lot of emotions
and they're always big.
They're Texas size.
So, we thought it would be fun
to play a little game called
What is Kelly Reacting To?
I just like to talk about myself.
So we're going to play a game
where I talk about myself
in the third person.
(laughing)
All right, here we go.
(upbeat music)
Okay, so here it is
reaction one.
(screaming)
What?
I'm so dramatic.
(screaming)
Okay.
I would guess
maybe this is cause this
is where I'm at right now
I keep finding freaking
rats in my backyard
and I'm just like, not in to this.
And so I'm currently changing my backyard.
So maybe that's what's
happening right now in my world.
So that's why I'm guessing
this is what my face looks
like right now in my backyard
like while watering my plants
and all of a sudden I look over
and there's this fat rat.
Fat healthy rat
just looking at me like
yeah, there's others too.
And like, literally this is my reaction.
This is what I look like in my backyard.
So I'm gonna say I'm reacting to an animal
doing something that you
don't want them to do.
That's when I'm reacting to.
Let's see what I was reacting to.
- [Shin] MGM.
Ohhhh, I remember this!
I love magic!
I remember this now.
What?
- Kelly, I didn't go anywhere
near that card, did I?
- No.
I don't think so.
- [Shin] It's slightly got
just a little bit.
- I love magic.
- [Shin] Just tear the card
right in the middle this time.
- I don't like this.
- Just gently tear.
(laughing)
No no, just tear midway through.
- Tear it?
- [Shin] Like you're tearing an envelope.
- [Kelly] Tear it?
- You see one card.
Here, I'll do it.
I'll help you.
(screaming)
- No, no, no, no.
- How does this happen?
Careful, hey, careful.
It's a delicate card.
Oh my God, wait, what?
What is happening?
- It looks like the MGM
grants to me, I think.
Let me just see.
- [Kelly] My mind is blown, dude.
(cheering)
Oh my God.
I love magic.
I am like
I just recently watched
this Lucifer episode.
The newest season that's out right now.
The last season
and he loves magic and
he doesn't want to know
like how you do it.
I'm like that.
I'm a child.
I don't really want to figure it out.
I like being amazed.
Anyways, so it turns out it wasn't rats.
That's just my real life.
So, that's great.
Okay, so reaction two.
I'm hitting someone with a pillow.
I must know this person, right?
Surely.
Oh my!
I'm deranged.
I'm just hitting a guest.
(laughing)
I don't know.
I'm hitting someone that I
hopefully know well.
But I seem to be a little
jealous of something.
I don't know what I'm jealous of.
I don't remember this.
Let's see how crazy I am.
Every picture I see you in
you always look like you work out all day.
Like, do you always work
don't tell me that.
- I, I.
- Is this natural?
Is this genetic?
- It's like a Hawaiian.
I don't, I don't
I'm not a fan of working out.
Well, we work out so much.
Like Aquaman, it's all the time.
And so when we're done.
I haven't touched a
weight since we wrapped
which is like two and a half years ago.
It's just too much.
- It's such a blessing for you.
(laughing)
Do you eat really healthy?
- No.
- [Kelly] Oh my!
- I mean, I eat slightly healthy.
I eat slightly healthy.
- You know why Jason Mamoa
you lie.
You lie to people.
When you look like that
you tell us that you work
every hour of the day
on your physical form
when you come out of the house like that.
Cause some of us can
work and work and work
and it's just, yeah.
Or you don't work
and you're just over it.
And you're like, that was
my twenties and thirties
and not the latter thirties.
But yeah, no.
I was angry at
and I don't know him that well.
(laughing)
And I just flung him with a pillow.
Welcome to the Kelly Clarkson Show.
Great.
Good for you.
Okay, let's see what this one is.
Reaction three.
Oh.
Okay wait.
Okay, I remember
on an episode
two young girls and they mix
something crazy together.
It was like Kool-Aid
and something Kool-Aid.
I don't know.
That might be it.
I tried something that they said
is like one of their favorite things.
This might be it.
I don't know if it is though.
- When I'm lazy
I just eat anchovy toast
and it has become my favorite snack.
And it's
I put it with like rye bread and butter
and just a couple
anchovies with lemon zest.
- I secretly kind hate you
cause I don't want to do it.
I feel like I'm on fear factor.
Holy
word I can't say.
Okay.
(laughing)
Oh my God.
Gross.
(laughing)
(bell)
That was good.
(laughing)
- Really?
- Yeah okay, it looks like
at the end it wasn't so bad
but no.
Anchovy toast, that's what you crave.
I wish that's what I craved.
And I don't think anchovy toast
is ever going to be my jam.
But it looks like it wasn't horrible
cause I would just
it would come back out of my mouth.
Like I'd spit it out
if it was not doable.
I'm strong, so I can take a lot.
Oh, I like this outfit.
I do remember this outfit.
Reaction four.
No no no no no no.
No no no no no.
Oh, I said something that
sounded sexual or something
I think.
Oh, no no no no no no no no no.
No no no no no.
Did I say something that's
I've had this face before.
It happens a lot, actually.
Where I say something and I'm like
that wasn't how it was
supposed to come out.
I bet a lot of money
that's what happened here.
Do you ever run into any
like celebrity crushes?
So I had a crush on Michael Fassbender.
My EP had said to us
yeah, Retta you don't
remember Michael Fassbender?
I was like, no.
He's like
he walked up to the table.
He smiled at you
instead of responding
you just leaned back and said
you know, I like black girls.
(laughing)
So.
- You've played yourself twice.
You just really did not want him
and inside your body, I think.
Well congratulate
oh oh oh oh
no no no no no no no no.
No no no no no no.
(laughing)
No.
That is not what I meant.
(cheering)
(laughing)
I meant like inside your core.
Not that way.
Yeah.
I do that a lot.
Here's the thing
like sometimes I have
this thing where I don't
I have the whole conversation in my head
but only let you in on just a bit of it.
And so
it comes out wrong.
I meant like, you know
in your core and you were
just kind of like, nah.
It did not come out that way.
It sounded like something else.
That happens a lot.
Every day.
Okay wait, reaction five.
Oh, New York.
(screaming)
What was I so happy about?
How do I not lose my voice?
Like screaming like that.
That is so not vocally
I know.
And it was like, it had some bravado.
It was weird.
I have no idea what I'm reacting
reacting to.
- I just finished wrapping up
the sequel to Enchanted in a.
(screaming)
- I love that movie!
Oh, did she say Enchanted Two?
That's what it was.
(screaming)
I'm loving
I'm doing it again.
This is the reaction
that we're talking about.
I love Enchanted.
I love it.
It's such a great film.
It's so cute.
Oh my God, I could watch
Enchanted a billion times over.
Susan Sarandon's so great.
Everybody's so great in it.
Like all the actors.
And I love it.
And I thought it was brilliant.
And so, I'm very excited
about the second one.
What is this?
This is Christmas time.
Oh my God, that's horribly awesome.
Horrible awesome.
I don't know if I'm into it.
Oh my God, that's horribly awesome.
Something didn't go well
but I don't know what happened here.
It's Christmas time.
My dress.
I don't know what this is.
And find out, wait for it
who is the Christmostest hostess?
♪ The Christmostest hostess ♪
Oh my God, that's horribly awesome.
Okay.
(laughing)
Okay, here's the thing
I should have guessed that.
Cause their jingles.
Sometimes I'm jealous
cause I'm like
y'all just get to meet
up on like a Monday night
and just like drink
and come up with these jingles.
I'm like, cause they're awesome.
There are so many little jingles they do
and they enjoy it.
Even the cheesiest
or the most inappropriate sounding
but kind of funny.
All right, that's all for today.
I'm dramatic.
I think that's what we've already known.
We didn't learn that today.
Hashtag extreme reactions
that that's me.
You know what, touche.
This is the real thing.
I am a lot.
You're welcome for the waste of time.
(laughing)